[Music]
what's going on you freaking leakers i'm
craig tea' I'll be your host today over
here at the leaking news and Boyd we got
some killer murderous reports here to
talk about today news coming out of
Disney Marvel some gaming news as well
and here to help me out today is
first-time guests fellow youtuber Greg
Alba from the real rage X Greg how's it
going man hey correct thanks for having
me man my pleasure my pleasure now
correct correct before we go into the
show we want to give a little plug and
tell people who you are which all doubt
yeah sure
my name is Greg I run a YouTube channel
called the real rejects over there we do
like reactions reviews movie news
sketches every once in a while you know
[ __ ] like that no Greg you said you do
reactions does that just mean people are
watching your face while you're watching
like a YouTube video or a trailer or
something yeah yeah I mean I know it
sounds silly when you hear it but I
think what people also really like about
us is that we do our best to provide
like commentary that way you're still
getting like actual content on top of
the reaction as well we edited all that
jazz uh-huh uh-huh now in terms of your
content do people actually stay after
the reaction to watch your content or do
they usually just click off well hold
that thought I do want to shout out a
patron today and if you guys have a
particular question you'd like to ask
join the leaking patreon page today and
if you're in the $50 tier you'll get put
into a monthly raffle or maybe just
maybe I'll consider answering your
question
maybe awesome how many people are in
that tier a lot Greg oh make a lot of
money a lot of people are in that dear
oh yeah but in all honesty it all just
goes to keeping the lights on around
here pay my one or two employees
depending on the day cuz let's face it
what we do here is really really hard
important necessary working about we I
mean I I believe you and I'm picking up
on sir
I'm on that tone no hmm well I just
watched your reaction just now and I
gotta say yeah just pissed me off just a
little bit just a little bit a little
pissed off of you right now
I'm sorry so two days ago we landed a
milestone first patreon page ever to do
so here's a graphic for you we broke 1
million patrons unbelievably grateful
for the love and support that you
frickin leakers have gone and showed our
way and with the channel memberships and
merge that I constantly provoke but
often forget to wear it was important
that I find a way to supplement that
income for my lifestyle that YouTube ads
can no longer provide on their own I am
planning on finding a charity where I
can donate maybe five six percent of all
earnings to the charity just gotta find
the right charity well what about one
that goes towards kovat or like black
lives
okay Craig Greg host talking please our
first question today comes from user X
self-loathing [ __ ] X he writes today
hey Craig biggest fan of the show been
watching since February 14 2005 the day
YouTube was launched I'm now 40 years
old and still haven't found a Valentine
with canceled culture canceling people
who did blackface TV shows going into
the archives to remove episodes
featuring blackface
are there any leaks or hot scoops he can
give us with this development well
thanks for the question next
self-loathing [ __ ] X now what he's
talking about is how shows like 30 rock
are going back into the archives and
removing episodes that featured black
faced recently Jimmy Kimmel was called
out for doing sketches that feature
blackface which were hilarious
I'm all for representation diversity X
cetera as long as it feels natural as
long as it feels organic as long as it
doesn't feel shoved down my throat
because otherwise when it's white people
I don't even notice it now before I go
into it more Greg what are your thoughts
on this I mean I think representation is
important I think people get the memo
now that you know blackface is wrong
blackface what a funny concept and while
I full heartedly support the black lives
matter movement
I don't know what you're really
accomplishing or helping out by by you
know removing episodes of 30 rock or
Golden Girls yes thank you thank you I'm
so [ __ ] glad you're here Thank You
Gregg you're welcome my sources my
sources are telling me removing episodes
from television shows that already are
off the air is only the beginning it's
only the beginning well my sources are
telling me it's that they're making
peter farrelly redo his Oscar speech for
winning Best Picture of greenbook to
properly thank Maher shali do do people
still care about that my sources are
also telling me that HBO max is
temporarily removing friends so they can
deep fake faces of people of color onto
the cast for re-release that can't be my
sources and my sources are never wrong
and if they are I want to admit it now
recently you may have heard Mike Henry
who voices the hysterical character
Cleveland Brown on the show Family Guy
step down from the role so a black
person can step in now Hank Azaria
already stopped voicing the character
appoo which is a shame cuz if it wasn't
for that character I'd be scared to walk
into any 7-eleven wait why now there's
the voice-over actor Harry Shearer who
voices mr. burns Ned Flanders Principal
Skinner and he also voices the doctor on
The Simpsons dub the black guy whatever
his name is he's now being removed from
the role and this next one infuriates me
David Herman who voices the black
transgender character on Bob's Burgers
he's now being removed to be replaced by
Hannibal Buress oh wow now what I've
been hearing from my sources is that
Nancy Cartwright the woman who voices
Bart Simpson on The Simpsons after all
these decades is being forced to step
down from playing the famous character
really yes now this one I agree with
look I don't know who's gonna fill in
for Cleveland Brown but let's face it no
black person can do it better than him
well I mean uh maybe and for the
Simpsons what kind of message are we
sending for our young boys in America
well one of the most iconic young boys
portrayed on television is played by a
woman right a role for woman don't just
keep giving them roles that belong to
the Dom the male species lately you just
defended the guy from Bob's Burgers
that's a different thing I'm sorry to do
this hunt your show Craig but Frank I
just have to ask are you racist I'm not
sexist
I didn't ask that well no to whatever
you asked why would you insult me with
such a question I mean you seem really
upset about the Bob's burger guy being
removed that's a different thing is it
yes the character is transgender does it
really matter this is a different
conversation Greg this is about talented
hard-working actors and some actresses
who are being unfairly pressured to
remove or walk away from things they
earned ah you see this is the problem
this is the problem you people on the
far left all you want to do is disagree
in a non civil manner just want to take
people down ask my 85% white male
audience ten percent people of color
from southern states and five percent
female demographic they know the real me
I don't understand why I don't
understand why you're so like getting
mad at me I'm not sexist or racist every
once in a while I might say something
from the heart from the mind the
subconscious areas where I'm not even
thinking before I speak and realizing I
have a camera pointed at me but I'm just
being honest and speaking in facts does
that make me racist or sexist no the far
left is all about outrage we need
honesty and sincerity our next story
today which relates disney buys the
rights to the bible what that's right
folks
Disney has now a
acquire the rights to the Bible where
they'll now have access to use any of
the characters from the Bible and any
one of their franchises now my sources
yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry to cut you off
who are your sources exactly they're my
sources my sources you can't have them
I don't want your sources I just think
it's important to know where you're
getting your information you know what
you're not gonna pay it today just sit
right there my sources have told me what
Disney plans on doing with the
characters from the Bible you may have
guessed and that's right folks
Marvel Jesus is joining the MCU now I
got early access to a press release that
Kevin Feige is putting out tomorrow but
for you freaking leakers I got the early
press release today he goes on to say
well we have accomplished over the last
15 years of superhero cinema has been
nothing short of a miracle
now it's time to introduce the real
miracle worker with superheroes being
touted as this generations Greek gods we
thought it'd be great to not only fuse
Greek and Norse mythology into the MCU
but now Christianity Thor love and
thunder will open up further realms
where we will introduce characters from
the Bible eventually leading to Jesus
leading the Avengers believers assemble
I got to admit some pretty inspiring
[ __ ] if you ask me now at first this
news shocked me it completely blew my
mind I grew up on Jesus Christ Superstar
I go to Mass twice a year Easter and
Christmas and I love how Family Guy uses
Christ to showcase he's got a sense of
humor the guy's got a sense of humor
perfect for the Marvel brand and I love
Marvel what they've been doing is
incredible what better way to resurrect
oh no no pun intended to reintroduce
Jesus Christ a man with an already
amazing origin story died on the cross
came back to life can resurrect people
from the dead can't walk on water can
turn water into wine while walking on
water and don't
me on this but I believe he can read
minds so this idea of Jesus coming into
the MCU you're gonna ask me Craig are
you excited about this and my answer
initially is yes yes viewer leaker I am
excited about this but why did you say
initially well there's some further
reports I have to leak to you guys today
you know how Marvel and Disney can be
they get pressured and they are slaves
to woke culture that's right
Jesus is joining the MCU but they're
making him a woman now I don't know how
you guys feel about it but not my Jesus
hashtag not my Christ but it doesn't
stop there they're not they're not only
making Jesus a woman they're making him
a black woman what culture is ruining
everything
there's plenty plenty of female
characters from the Bible they can
choose from to adapt to bring a female
character from the Bible to life there's
Mary the Virgin Mary Mother of Christ
there's Mary Magdalene the prostitute
there's some others that aren't coming
to mind right now if you want to bring
Jesus to the big screen I'm all for it
I'm all for it peace be with you I say
but to make him a woman I don't know
Disney I don't know okay call me crazy
now granted I wouldn't have a career if
I didn't spend all my time talking about
the hard work that you guys put out on a
daily basis but this is [ __ ] whoa
culture is ruining everything might as
well ask you Greg what do you think who
told you this go [ __ ] yourself now I
don't know what else to add here but
what do you guys think are you on the
same page as me and let me know down
below make sure to take to Twitter to
voice how you really feel about it
because let's face it that's the best
place to have this kind of conversation
this last bit of news I want to talk
about today and I'll keep it brief I
feel like maybe people will think I'm
the
a little harsh on certain areas of the
business today what's fine that's fine
if you think that you're entitled to
your own opinion but hey someone wants
to call him out right now Laura Bailey
who voices Abbey the character in the
Last of Us - she's been getting a lot of
hate via social media death threats to
be specific now if you haven't played
the game I won't spoil it for you she's
been receiving death threats and I won't
show the one she's put out but I'll
share with you guys the ones that stood
out to me the most here um this user
says my court-ordered therapist says I
should think before I say or do
something completely idiotic well at
Laura Bailey you should have done the
same thing before committing the actions
you did this next post says I don't know
how to deal with my own lack of
self-worth and I can't distinguish the
difference between reality and what's
fiction
so you should go kill yourself Laura
Bailey cuz you're responsible for my
problems basically it's a kelly Murray
transition all over again this voice
actress is being blamed for the actions
of a video game character one that she
did not write or even mocap for to say
the least and now she's receiving death
threats and honestly when are these
women gonna learn to stop making
stupid-ass decisions with taking on
these roles
the second you portray a character even
in the slightest bit of a voiceover work
it is now entirely your fault for
ruining our lives video games movies
shows it's not just fiction people this
is our existence and instead of replying
Laura Bailey you instead shared one of
my tweets publicly shame on you shame on
you it is my job to shame you reply back
to me just grow a pair ooh
hooks is to say dick ulis in other news
I got an email that people are gonna be
protesting the grave of Alan Rickman for
portraying Snape recently during
quarantine a lot of people ended up
rewatching the half-blood Prince and
they're pretty mad at Snape killed
Dumbledore so they're taking it to the
grave I'll be there feel free to join me
could be a meet and greet that's all for
today folks tune in next week for more
amazing freaking leaking movie news and
Greg Alba you're a [ __ ]
[Music]